[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGAN SMITH: Hello, and welcome
to Women Techmakers.
This is the first of a series
that we hope to send to you
from Google Live.
We started with a panel at
Google I/O last year, the
night before I/O. It was
incredibly popular, and so we
decided that we would
expand the series.
We want to talk to amazing
women in our industry.
And today we have
Leslie Bradshaw.
So before we start,
my background is--
I've been at Google for almost
10 years, leading new business
development and M&A.
Today, I'm a vice
president over in Google[x]
team.
And I'm joined by Betsy.
BETSY MASIELLO: Hi, I'm Betsy.
I've been at Google for about 4
years, and I'm on the public
policy team.
And I work on a variety of
different policy issues.
One of my favorites is how data
can be used to transform
the economy.
MEGAN SMITH: So one of our ideas
with women techmakers is
that there's an amazing number
of women in our industry
already, and throughout the
history of our industry who
have had a huge impact.
And so we want to raise the
visibility of them, even
though we often are frustrated
by the percentages.
Sometimes in teams we'll see
10%, 20%, or 30% women.
But the women who are here
are fierce, fabulous, and
contributing a lot.
And so our goal with this
series is not only to
highlight the astounding
contributions they're making,
but also encourage more people,
men and women, to join
the tech industry.
So, OK, welcome Leslie
Bradshaw.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Thank
you, both.
MEGAN SMITH: Our first guest.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yes,
the hot seat.
MEGAN SMITH: So you are the
president, COO, and co-founder
of JESS3, the amazing data
visualization company.
Can you talk a little bit about
what you guys do and
what you're thinking about?
LESLIE BRADSHAW: So what
we do is really bring
information to life.
And I think not a day goes by
that there's not another
article about big data, and big
data problems, and what
are you doing with your data?
And one of the most important
things is not just only the
analyzing and kind of
algorithmic work around the
data, but it's that final
mile, the visual.
And making sure that people
are engaging, and being
educated, and absorbing
the information.
So we've really decided to
specialize on that front and
tip of the spear with data.
MEGAN SMITH: It would be fun,
I think, to show people some
of things you guys
have worked on.
And when we were talking,
preparing a little bit, you
talked about the range of
different kinds of products
you guys do.
Whether they're full live or
whether they're sort of more
of a static traditional
visualization.
Do you want to kind of share
a little bit of that?
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yeah, there's
really a continuum.
When you think of data
visualization and you're in
tech, you're thinking
interactive.
And that's probably the most
dynamic, interesting kind of
API-based data visualization.
But on the other end of the
spectrum, you have static.
And that's what you'd see
mostly on Mashable with
infographics and I think the
stuff that's been put out
there by the sports industry
and financial
industry for years.
It's about telling stories
with data.
"The Economist" does a fantastic
job of little spark
lines and pie charts.
And then in between you have
animation [INAUDIBLE]
has pioneered in terms
of geocoding all
of the polling locations.
So there's just amazing--
data.gov.
There's a lot of sources
of data out there.
And then, you then need to
analyze it and come up with
some outcomes and some potential
logic that's going
to power your system.
And that's probably the hardest
thing for people who
aren't engineers to do and think
about because there's a
lot of conditions, a lot of
if-thens that you have to
think ahead about.
And I think most people want to
just push a few buttons and
then have things compare and
then reconfigure themselves.
I would say infographics are
an easier lift because that
way you're able to hit pause
on the data, look at it,
snapshot it, and then come out,
what we call as in the
narrative phase.
And just as if you're writing
a paper in college, you need
to have a thesis, supporting
evidence, and a conclusion.
And that's what we've
done in both the
static and the motion.
Whereas, interactive, it's
a shifting ground.
The conclusion changes
as the data change.
MEGAN SMITH: Let's show an
example of something.
We've been lucky to
work with you guys
tomorrow as the US election--
for those here in the
US listening.
There's a visualization we've
done with the news and
politics team at Google,
actually with you guys.
And so I don't know if
we can flip to that.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yeah, we've
been working closely with the
Google politics team out
in Washington, DC.
And what we've been doing is
taking the search data and
search interest around key,
decisive moments.
Whether it's a debate and
seeing, at what point did
people-- what were
search spikes?
When people were looking
up the word "Biden" and
"malarkey?" Or, what was it--
"horses" and "bayonets." Those
were some of the search terms
that were spiking during
the debates.
We were also very active
during the primaries in
looking at which candidates were
surging in which states.
And one of the things-- and I
know Google won't necessarily
say this, but I'll go
ahead and say it.
It became very predictive
of outcomes in
states to see what--
going in probably three to seven
days out, what states
were interested and what
counties even were interested
in which candidates were
correlating very closely with
the outcomes in those states.
So it was a really exciting
thing for us to be able to
kind of watch this
huge data set.
And to take something where
Gallup normally would be
polling people by phone and a
certain kind of end example.
Whereas Google, the sample
is much larger and it
geographically has integrity
as far as who's
searching for what.
So a lot of the Google work,
really excited about tomorrow.
And we've been working with all
you for about a year now.
MEGAN SMITH: Thank you.
And then, maybe another
example.
Which one should we pop to?
Do you want to talk
about the Samsung?
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yeah, let's
talk about the Samsung wall a
little bit.
What we've done at various live
events, I think that's
one place where user-generated
content really spikes and the
data set becomes interesting.
And what we did with Samsung in
both 2011 and again in 2012
at the South by Southwest
Interactive Festival.
And looked at what terms
were trending.
What startups were starting
to surge.
What panelists were getting
the most chatter.
And then, of course, the night
life, which parties were the
most popular, who was
checking in where.
MEGAN SMITH: Which
is really fun.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yeah.
We're looking at that kind
of outcome screens.
But even going through our
thinking and our processes,
what information is going to be
important to that end user?
You've got people
walking around
and badges and hungover.
What kind of information
do they need to know?
Well, they need to know
where the panels are.
And if they're missing the
panels or they're stuck in
line, what's being said
and being shared?
And that was something that
we really watched.
It was at a point throughout the
event that certain pieces
of news were breaking.
There was a rumor that CNN was
going to buy Mashable.
And all of a sudden, our screen
showed all of the
people discussing it.
And everybody's eyes just kind
of glued to it as if it was
the TV station.
So we're always looking
at live events.
Obviously, politics,
sporting events.
We did a project around the
NFL and Superbowl XLV with
Twitter and just looked at ways
that fans were excited
and talking trash, and
going back and forth.
And those are really the moments
where the data spikes.
And then, things start getting
interesting at that point.
BETSY MASIELLO: A lot of what
you're describing is sort of a
new way of sociology, measuring
what's happening in
real-time using all this data.
And I think you were telling
me, as we were preparing
earlier, that you had
studied sociology a
little bit in school.
What was your path like to get
from that to what is now a
very data-intensive sort
of role in life?
LESLIE BRADSHAW: I think when
we all go to high school and
college, there's probably
about five jobs we can
conceive of.
There's an astronaut,
a firefighter,
a teacher, a lawyer.
And I thought I was going to be
a lawyer because I thought,
oh, that's what some of
my family members do.
That's what smart people do.
Make some money.
And you go into school, and then
all of a sudden you get
exposed most often to this
liberal arts education.
And you're just eating
from the buffet of
education and life.
And I loved sociology
and statistics.
And then I'm over here and I'm
learning about Western
civilization.
So there was a lot of courses
that I took at the University
of Chicago that just, my mind
was open and it was cross
disciplinary, and it was just
a lot of intellectual
cultivation, I guess.
So you go through that and
then you graduate.
And then you need
to get a job.
And at that point I said, OK,
well, I've been an assistant
paralegal at a few law
firms back home.
I guess I'll be a lawyer.
I guess I'll go in
that direction.
And while there at my first law
firm, it was at the moment
when a lot of the phishing
scandals and a lot of the
domain name squatting
was occurring.
And I was helping track
those violations.
I would screenshot the source
code or I'd screenshot the
domain name violation, pull up
the trademark, and make a
little file.
It started to dawn on me that
there was this kind of
cataclysmic shift as brands
were coming online and as
other people were exploiting
brands that there was
something to the digital
brand management.
And I think that's really where
I started saying, OK,
there gold in them
there hills.
And not that I was early to say
that because it was 2005
and .com had already
come through.
But it was starting to impact
brands in a way that I think
forever changed the way they
approached their brand
management.
MEGAN SMITH: Almost like a pure
digital agency, which is
where you guys, as
a team, came.
In fact, to the level where as
you started, I think everybody
was in different cities.
Is that true?
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yeah.
So with JESS3 what we were
starting to realize is working
at traditional agencies, working
in law firms, there
was just a lack of grabbing onto
this new frontier in a
really holistic way.
People were digitizing records
and trying to kind of think
beyond email.
But it wasn't happening fast
enough for our liking.
So my business partner and I,
we were 24 at the time.
And he was doing a lot of
freelance work and I was kind
of getting a little bit bored
filing papers and
screenshotting source
code all day.
So we started building out a
bit of a company that we
decided we weren't going to
draw specifically from our
geography, but we were going
to use the internet to find
the best talent.
And at the time, most people
would put their
portfolio work on Flickr.
But over the years, now you have
things like Behance and
Dribbble, and Forest.
And we're able to identify kind
of the best in class.
And going to blogs like
infosthetics and Information
is Beautiful, you see whose work
is featured and you say--
everybody has a rate.
We were able to even work
with Nicholas Felton
who's now at Facebook.
And we worked with him on an
infographic years ago because
we just reached out and said,
hey, we love your work.
And we had a project
and collaborated a
little bit with him.
MEGAN SMITH: That's a great
best practice for--
in visualization you can see
amazing work and then go get
those people.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: It is.
It's a very, very transparent
industry.
And every once in a while,
you'll get someone who puts a
portfolio piece up that they
were one team member of a
larger team.
But by and large, it's kind of
what you see is what you get.
MEGAN SMITH: You've had
people from Poland.
You guys were in DC.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: We were
in Washington, DC.
And in a lot of ways, I thought
of us less as an
agency and more--
there was almost kind of this
supply chain management that
was going on because I'd wake
up at a certain time and I
would check-in with people that
were producing graphics.
And then I'd have to check-in
with the animators who were in
a different city.
It was a lot of coordination.
And I would definitely say that
the cloud played a huge
part in even being able
to conceive that we
were able to do it.
But I will also say that there
has been so many times that
when we all come together and
work together, we do a Google
War Room every time
we have an event.
And that's when it just--
it's more efficient.
And certainly there's a lot to
be said about the cloud, but
the human interaction I've come
to really appreciate in
the last year or so.
MEGAN SMITH: You guys have
explosive growth.
The things in Fast Company, Inc,
everybody's saying you
guys are just--
it's an amazing story.
And so it's sort of--
I don't know if you can talk a
little bit about the fly the
plane and build the plane
at the same time kind of
experience you guys have
been going through.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Well, as I
noted, it started with my
partner and I. Then we had
a couple of freelancers.
And we were throttling between
doing work for local
businesses, and doing logos,
and that kind of work.
And we were stretching at the
same time, because we saw this
user-generated content
opportunity.
We were leveraging, originally
Delicious and
Flickr had good APIs.
And then, eventually Twitter
came online.
And of course, Facebook
opened their platform.
So we really decided, first
and foremost, let's
specialize.
Let's specialize in data
visualization.
And let's go a step further and
let's even specialize in
social media data
visualization.
And it's kind of like betting
on the right horse because
those things were kind of
up and to the right.
And as those user basis got
larger and the volume and
velocity of their content got
bigger, there were brands who
wanted to take that and
make sense of it.
There were people who wanted
business intelligence and
insights off of it.
So that really was a big part
of our explosive growth was
the specialization and
capitalizing off of the
proliferation of APIs.
The second thing about the
growth is that it really came
down to just really trusting and
going after what we knew
was the right thing.
Unlike startups and
products, we don't
have any venture funding.
So this is 100% bootstrapped,
cash flow management, kitchen
table business, hope we make
payroll, hope that check comes
in on time.
But in a way, you have these
amazing brands, like Google
and Red Bull and NASA,
underwriting your
experimentation.
So we did a lot of prototyping
in the early days.
One big piece of advice I always
love to give is, don't
wait for a client to pay you.
Take some of those profits
and reinvest.
And I think that some of our
projects, like the I Voted
project where we did the first
kind of visual, real-time
civic participation.
We also did another project
called The Geosocial Universe,
a very simple graphic that just
showed the enormity of
mobile versus some of the more
kind of Lilliputian, Gowalla
at the time and Foursquare.
And those are things that are
proofs of concept that later
turned into lead generation.
And kind of proved out something
that we knew that we
could do, but nobody was
yet paying us to do it.
MEGAN SMITH: Almost
like how you found
some of your artists.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Exactly.
Yeah, so it's kind of you've got
to chum the water a little
bit, and then get people to
think in the way that you know
that you can deliver on.
Really, actually amazing, our
first Google project came
about because we made a video
called "The State of the
Internet." And at the time,
we had never done a video.
And we were going to a lot
of lectures and local
universities and just talking
about the growth of the
internet was being driven by
social media, and social media
is something that is
very flexible and
everybody can get involved.
And we wanted to show that.
And we did it usually through
a few slides.
We said, you know what?
We're going to do a video.
So we put this video out.
And lo and behold, big
surprise, it goes
viral on the internet.
A video about the internet goes
It's very meta.
And we got a call from Google
and the Google Translate team.
And they were looking for a
motion graphics team, and they
had seen our video.
And little did they know it was
the only video we'd ever
done at that point.
But fake it till you make it.
And it turned into a project
where we did the official
About video for the
translate team.
And it was a lot of fun.
BETSY MASIELLO: Very cool.
You said you were
only 24 when you
started this whole venture.
And you and your partner Jesse
are not in the first
generation of leaders
in this space.
Where do you see this
interactive space going?
And then, where do you
want to take it?
So one thing I see companies
that are being founded today,
there's not a clear line of, oh,
it's a service business or
it's a product business.
I think terms like creative
technologists are emerging.
People are hiring data
scientists that are not just
at Oracle, but anybody who's
trying to analyze metrics and
make kind of mission-critical
decisions.
So I would say there's a fusion
between the art of
marketing and the science of
technology in Silicon Valley.
And what we've said of our firm,
we want to fuse Madison
Avenue and Silicon Valley.
Now we're based in Los Angeles
and we also want to fuse
Hollywood in there.
So we're kind of throwing
all three together.
But I don't think we're
the only ones.
I think there's a lot of other
companies who are looking at
the proliferation of content,
and trying to make sense of it
and put it in a way that is
discernible and digestible.
And at the same time, looking
for ways to storytell and
looking for ways to
engage people.
And then also, monetize it.
And add some kind of layer of
payment and the ability to
kind of keep growing.
So I would say, by
and large, it's a
fusion of art and science.
And where we want to
take it is just
through those three doors.
We want to continue to work
with the Madison Avenue
brands, and help
them storytell.
But at the same time, we want
to have our own prototyping
and products division where
we're taking some of our
learnings while we're processing
all of this data
and thinking about, well, gosh,
if every client comes to
us every year around the
Oscars or the Olympics,
there's a product here.
There's a way to
visualize that.
And I think there's certainly
some smart folks getting into
this space and specializing
only in that.
You have somebody like a Mass
Relevance or, on the business
intelligence side, Radian6
or Crimson Hexagon.
But nobody's specializing
specifically in
the design of it.
Whenever they close a round of
funding, they always say, oh,
we're having 60 engineers.
But you don't really hear them
talk a lot about UI designers
or graphic artists.
And I think that's where we've
really differentiated and also
partnered with firms that
specialize more
on that back end.
MEGAN SMITH: It's really
important because
visualization has a way-- it
certainly reminds me some of
the greatest change comes
from storytelling.
You may have the data, but
until you storytell well
around it, nobody really gets
the point, or they don't see
how it connects to them,
or there's no
sort of call to action.
And so you guys are the visual
form of that in a really
interesting way.
Another example that might be
fun to show or great to show
would be the one that you guys
did with American Express.
In fact, that's a static
version, but it has to do with
change for women in business.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: This is
one, of course, near
and dear to my heart.
Near and dear, I'm sure, to
the audience as well.
But American Express did a great
job of pulling a lot of
data out of the Census report in
2010 and looked at a lot of
the small business growth.
And just how women were driving
growth in, I think it
was 7 out of 13 major
categories.
And just the economic impact
of women-owned businesses.
Now, they released a report
in the spring.
And a lot of people picked it up
more just kind of based on
some of the factoids.
But they thought, there's a
longer shelf life to this.
So we ended up creating 90
pieces of content with them.
One is a large infographic that
shows just kind of the
overall path from starting a
company to the growth and the
kind of macroeconomic impact.
And then what we did is we
worked with individual
entrepreneurs and we asked
them questions.
MEGAN SMITH: Is this the one?
Yeah, this is the one.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: "Your Business,
Your Goals, Your
Journey." And then we worked
with individual entrepreneurs
who would tell their story.
So there was a kind of
storytelling through data, and
then there was more of a
qualitative storytelling
through the women who were
doing this themselves.
And we used some terms,
we call it
socially optimized content.
Now, an infographic, when you
look at some of those
scrolling ones and you try to
put it on your G+ page or your
Facebook page, they become
really hard to read.
So what we've done is we kind
of optimize it for the
particular dimensions
on the platform.
So we create snackable
graphics.
So it kind of cracks open,
kind of in a fractal way,
takes the big infographic and
maybe makes 10 smaller
graphics out of it.
So part of the 90 pieces of
content, one was this anchored
mega infographic--
supergraphic which is what
Edward Tufte would call it.
And then, we had a lot of other
kind of snackable pieces
that were easier to share,
easier to see on your mobile,
easier to share on social, put
on Tumblr, that kind of thing.
MEGAN SMITH: This is a
huge contribution.
I was able--
for a little while at Google I
led kind of a transition of
google.org where we added more
engineering, like Google
Crisis Response and outreach
to nonprofits.
And one of my observations in
that particular space is that
people are doing amazing work,
but the end product when
they're communicating is often
a very thick journal or
written document that a subset
of people have sort of maybe
the background to read that,
or less people are able to
read that just because
they're busy.
So being able to do things like
this, sort of synthesize
the data, and then put it into
visual form is really, I
think, a high contribution and
an important skill, a 21st
century skill.
BETSY MASIELLO: You were talking
a little bit earlier
today about saying, have
you measured this on
decision-making?
And you were saying actually,
no, you've measured it on
consumption, which is
pretty interesting.
So you find that people are
actually consuming this
information when it's
in graphic form.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Anecdotally I
can say, one of our clients,
Nike, we do a lot of reporting
on growth of their social
platforms and how social is
kind of driving to their
commerce site.
And we were originally
delivering this.
We'd load it up in Google
Docs, and then
we'd export as a PDF.
And it was a written document.
And it seemed kind of
counter-intuitive because here
we are a visual storytelling
form and we're
delivering this Word doc.
And so what we ended up doing
is turning that information
into an infographic.
So every week, we produce
an infographic for Nike.
It's optimized for Keynote
or PowerPoint slide.
And it gives you
just the facts.
And its storytells with
qualitative and quantitative
information.
And I can tell you, everybody
looks forward to that.
It's something that the
executives have on their desk.
It's easier to kind of make an
argument or have a discussion
as opposed to having, as
you said, a big kind of
thick ream of paper.
And I've written plenty of big
thick reports in my life.
And I know that even the most
considerate, intelligent
people just do not
have the time.
And I think what information
design does is it distills it
down and really forces you to
kind of get those potent
nuggets in front of someone
in a faster way.
One of my favorite projects,
actually thinking about a big
ream of paper.
So we had 150-page
white paper.
And if we can pull it up.
If you even just Google
Economist and JESS3, it was a
project where they had done--
"The Economist" had put together
a study of 113
countries and the
global economic
opportunity for women.
And amazing project.
And it was something
that, again, near
and dear to my heart.
And it was "The Economist,"
so they've got great data.
But it was 150-page
white paper.
And you can just imagine there's
probably 8 people out
there, 4 of which are working
on a PhD and 4 of which are
probably paid to read it.
And they came to us and
we animated it in
the 6-minute piece.
And it was incredibly
powerful.
And we just saw it just spread
like wildfire online.
And it distilled down six
executive findings.
It story told about the gap
between policy and practice.
And it really illustrated that
in a very powerful way.
And that convinced me
immediately, from here on out,
any time I have a report it's
either going to be animated or
it's going to be designed in
an infographic because you
could just see the audience.
Because it was presented
at a forum, their
World in 2011 series.
And other people got up there
and kind of showed your
traditional slides.
And people kind of
checked out.
But the video, you could just
watch everyone's body posture
and their eye contact.
And so I think the consumption,
again, I don't
have the hard data.
But qualitatively, I've seen
people really engage better
with both video and infographic
content.
So I think it's a smart tool,
whether it's an internal
communication or whether you're
doing any kind of
consumer-facing communications.
IBM has done a great job.
Think about their Smarter
Planet, and that entire
campaign is an icon, data-driven
kind of thing.
And that's where consumers
are today.
They are more educated.
They are wanting to consume
Wikipedia and IMDb while
they're watching their
favorite show.
And brands are being smart to
put that information at their
fingertips.
BETSY MASIELLO: It's
not just consumers.
I think in the policy space,
a lot of what you've talked
about is sort of policy
relevant.
And certainly, there's a lot of
150-page reports floating
around out there about various
different policies--
MEGAN SMITH: That are
good, but they're
like not the end product.
They need to stop being
the end product.
We need the visualizations, and
then the social discussion
after that to be more of the
goal with the data behind it,
real good data.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Exactly.
Absolutely.
BETSY MASIELLO: So you
have a regular--
a column on forbes.com where you
advocate for women getting
more power seats.
Tell us a little bit about why
that's so important to you.
LESLIE BRADSHAW:
So I saw Sheryl
Sandberg's TED talk, TEDxWomen.
And she talked about there was a
couple of staff members from
George Bush's staff that gave
up seats and kind of stood
against the wall.
And she kind of used that as
this metaphor, more women need
to take that seat
at the table.
And looking up quite a bit to
Sheryl, I thought to myself,
not only do they need to sit at
the table, but they need to
be at the head of the table.
The idea of it's not just about
more seats, but it's
about more power seats.
I think we're seeing parity in
a lot of areas for women that
weren't here 50 years ago.
We think about education,
obtaining higher levels of
education, and master's degrees
and law degrees.
But it starts dropping off
the further up the
food chain you go.
And so what I advocate for is
that we don't want to see
single and low double-digit
numbers in Congress, in
venture capital funding,
in-- you name it.
Even the clergy I looked up and
it was 15% of all clergy
leadership are female.
So seeing those numbers get
closer to 50% is something
that I hope to see in my
lifetime across as many
industries as possible.
MEGAN SMITH: One thing that's
interesting is the president
of Harvey Mudd College has been
working hard on computer
science because computer science
for a very long time
has been 10% to 20% women
in the field.
Which doesn't make sense given
the impact and the fun in
what's out there.
But she was studying how the
entry point into that
particular major is
somehow not of
interest to women at scale.
And so she made three changes.
One of them was to take the
freshman to the Grace Hopper
Celebration on Women in
Computing, which is where
4,000 women get together who are
computer scientists at all
level from senior fellows to new
undergrads, so they could
see women in the field.
The second thing that
they did was change
the class entry point.
So that instead of straight
into programming, they
actually did things that showed
you what this field was
about, and challenge projects,
and then get into programming,
which was really important.
And they also did a little
bit of rework on the
attitude in the class.
And they had people, instead of
sort of let me prove to you
how I can code, it's more like,
hey, if you're really
good, why don't you prove how
well you can help other people
and turn people into more mentor
peers with sort of the
rock star programmers.
And they're at 42% women after
3 years in the computer
science program.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: I just
got goosebumps.
That's amazing.
MEGAN SMITH: Which is
really exciting.
Yeah.
So it's really, I think in a
lot of ways, showing people
how exciting these careers
are and how fun they are.
And whether you're
coding or whether
you're in the core team.
Because all of the tech teams
are really cross functional
teams of writers, and
visualization, and artists,
and people who keep the trains
running on time, and people
who run the back end of the
systems, front end, et cetera.
So helping people see a way into
that because there are so
many jobs in our field, it's
exciting to see finally when
there's a few bright spots.
Because it is pretty daunting,
the numbers are daunting.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: The numbers are
daunting, but I love this
idea of different
entry points.
I think one thing people often
say, oh, there's not enough
female technical people to
found companies and I'm
looking for a technical
founder.
And I think it's not the right
question to be asking is
whether or not you're that
hard core inner computer
science person, but there's
other things that can bring
you to that table.
There's people that can
do interaction design.
There are people
that can do the
operational side of things.
People that do HR piece of it.
It all needs to come together.
And certainly, when you look at
those numbers, I think the
number is more than just 20% to
30%, but probably expands
closer to that 50% that
we'd want it to be.
I look at my own company
and the way that--
the gender makeup.
And it's about 50-50.
We've had women.
We've had female programmers.
Our head of information design
is a woman and she's based in
England, Tiffany Gonzalez.
And we've had interactive
designers that are women.
It doesn't have to
be that kind of,
again, that hard core.
I think when you think of
somebody in their basement
programming or eating Cheetos
and drinking Mountain Dew or
Red Bull or something
like that.
I think that's that default
stereotype, but I think
there's a lot of other
entry points.
And I love that the program
that it sounds like Harvey
Mudd has been--
MEGAN SMITH: You can eventually
get to be the
Cheeto-eating programmer in the
basement, but not right
away on the path.
Talk a little bit
about school.
Because I think one of the other
things with women coming
into technology, having
confidence in yourself
[INAUDIBLE].
You actually have been an
entrepreneur for a long time.
You guys have a family farm.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: So one thing
I would say about my
upbringing is I've looked a
lot to my father and his
entrepreneurial self.
He didn't go to college and just
kind of started working
his way up through
various jobs.
And eventually, went from being
a ski lift operator in
Lake Tahoe to being a general
manager after 13 years.
So I saw my father go to work
early in the morning, late at
night, take any shit he could
get, and just learn every
aspect of the business.
So that in my mind was like,
OK, that's how you do it.
Learn every aspect of the
business and work your way up.
I think my parents also
instilled a lot of
confidence in me.
And I have a younger sister,
so it's just us girls.
And it wasn't, oh, boys do
certain things, girls do
certain things.
We were always very
active outdoors.
I loved science and math and
went to a science and math
camp and econ camp.
And that was always
encouraged.
So I never had a lack of
confidence, and probably could
be said atc certain points, I
probably have a little bit too
much confidence.
I think each personality is
going to develop differently.
There's probably men out there
with less confidence and the
women that are overconfident.
But in general, I think women
tend to put themselves second.
Whether they're sisters, or
mothers, or daughters, they're
always in this role of making
sure everyone's OK.
And when you make sure
everyone's OK, sometimes you
kind of take that foot
off the gas pedal.
Again, to use some Sheryl
Sandberg language in talking
about not stepping up and
saying, yes, I'll take that
opportunity.
But you know what?
Oh, Frank, he's been
working hard.
Let's have Frank have this one,
or giving the credit,
kind of further distributing
it.
And I think that those are some
really great traits of
the female gender.
But at the same time, they are
inhibiting, oftentimes, the
advancement and putting women
further at the top.
MEGAN SMITH: You were accepted
to University of
Chicago and to Davis.
And you decided not
to go to Chicago.
Say a little bit about that.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: So here I am,
I graduated from a rural high
school in Junction
City, Oregon.
And I was valedictorian and I
thought, OK, I'm going to go
make my way in the world.
And I was touring a couple
different schools, among them
Davis and Chicago.
And I went to Chicago and all
of the students had already
read all the texts
that they were
discussing in the classes.
They had gone to private
schools.
And I had no concept of this,
but they actually paid as much
to go to high school as I was
about to pay to go to college.
And it just completely
blew my mind.
And it was intimidating.
Honestly, it was very
intimidating.
And then I was offered a full
ride scholarship to UC-Davis.
Because I had grown up in
Northern California and
Oregon, I had family members
in Sacramento
and around the area.
I thought, OK, I'll go there.
And I'll tell you, two
weeks in, I knew I
made the wrong choice.
Davis is a wonderful place,
great school, really enjoyed
the professors.
But it was really large.
People weren't going
there for academic
inquiry at the volume.
It was kind of more
of a default.
Like, oh, I did pretty
well in high school.
I'm going to matriculate
to this school.
Whereas Chicago, highly
self-selecting.
You're on the South
Side of Chicago.
It's cold.
The school's hard.
You have to take
a lot of math.
And I decided to reapply.
And at that point when I
reapplied, I was talking with
the counselor.
And he said to me, Leslie, you
didn't just get in once, but
you got in twice.
So you do deserve to be here and
I hope you remember that
for the rest of your time.
So I ended up graduating
top 2% of my class.
And went to every single
lecture, did not
miss a single beat.
Because it was if you didn't,
everybody else
would kind of lap you.
So it was a really competitive
environment, but it was also
really kind of nerdy, and fun,
and being smart was cool.
And I loved that.
MEGAN SMITH: But I think it's
telling you've done this
amazing thing.
But to have a moment where sort
of confidence is taking
you in a different direction
is important.
I think that happens to a
lot of women and men.
And it's important to note that
that's a pretty normal
experience.
And then, you get
back up and go.
And just keep going.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: The one secret
to my success at JESS3,
and now looking back at the last
30 years of my life, it's
perseverance.
It's discipline.
It's showing up every
single day.
And there were so many points
throughout the last six years
that it would have been so
easy to walk away because
things got stressful, people
quit, project didn't go as
well as we'd like it to.
But I also knew that there
was more to come.
If we just kept showing up--
I knew that if I kept showing up
and putting my best in, and
showed that to the rest of the
team, then we could make it.
We've had a couple of
really great awards.
You mentioned we made the Inc
500 this year at number 430
with our growth.
And that took every
ounce of me.
Every blood, sweat, tears.
It's only been in the last few
months that I'm starting to
sleep regular hours again.
But for six years--
and for three of those
years mind you, I
had a full-time job.
So I was coming home, eating
dinner, rallying, working from
8:00 PM to 4:00 AM, collapsing,
rallying again,
getting back up and going
to my other job.
And did that straight for three
years until we finally
had enough money and potential
to make that bigger leap.
So there's, certainly again,
lots of times that you could
have just folded up and walked
away, but showing up every day
as I did, whether it's at
University of Chicago or with
JESS3, it's just
giving it 110%.
MEGAN SMITH: Yeah, showing up
at the place you want to be
and going for it.
I mean, you're at over $5
million in revenue at this
point, which is just amazing.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yes.
So when I look back and I add up
every single year, which I
do sometimes, we've officially
crossed the $10 million mark,
which is really just a big
number in my mind.
I can hardly even
think about it.
But it's every little check,
every little moment kind of
collected all in one place.
And this year, due in large part
to amazing partnerships
with clients like American
Express and we talked about
Google and Samsung.
Another one that we worked
with over years is Intel.
It doesn't get more Silicon
Valley than being able to work
with the chip maker that
made it all possible.
So it's been fantastic.
And to have the trust
of those brands--
and they're coming to us for
really fun prototyping,
experimental work.
And they're looking
to us to kind of
help them think through--
I always think of us almost as
the Navy seals who are kind of
dropping out of a black
helicopter and
kind of solving something.
And then kind of zip-cording
back up.
MEGAN SMITH: And then
it goes on.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Yeah,
it keeps going.
BETSY MASIELLO: We've
talked a lot about
your distributed team.
How do you think that
leadership--
how do you change your
leadership style to adapt to
what sounds like is a very
distributed global
team around the world?
LESLIE BRADSHAW: So one of the
things that I always try to do
is have as much face
time as possible.
And oftentimes, that face time
comes in the form of a Skype
session, or a Google Hangout.
Oftentimes, our information
design director is logging on
just as I'm logging off.
And I'll grab her on IM
and say, hey, Tiff,
let's just catch up.
And at that point, I always like
to hear from everyone and
just say, what are
you working on?
Any roadblocks?
Anything that you're
bumping up against?
I think also, we typically do
one to two summits a year
where we bring everyone together
as much as we can
from all over.
And that's an opportunity to
break bread together and to
finally work together in the
same room on a whiteboard.
And that's incredibly
important.
But also, making sure that we're
constantly celebrating
wins as a team.
And whether that's through our
blog, or tweeting it, or
sending around emails, there's
kind of a constant flow of
discussion groups that
are going on.
And then we have a couple of
other distribution lists and
list groups within
the company.
We have Ladies at JESS3.
We send around links when the
Anne-Marie Slaughter piece
came out in "The Atlantic," or
just different things that we
want to kind of rally around.
And we certainly make sure to
just reinforce contributions
from, oh, this person did this
and shout everybody out.
Because sometimes you've
never met the person.
Or people don't know who's
working on everything because
even though it's a small team
of 30, about 30 full-time,
there's dozens, if not hundreds,
of contractors
worldwide that are
contributing.
And to be able to pull everybody
in is tough, but
we've managed to do it.
MEGAN SMITH: There's a couple
questions on moderator.
So let's see, DBR in San
Francisco wants to know, how
do you balance growing head
count to be able to take on
more work with growing cash
flow to make pay?
How do you balance that?
And he or she is also saying,
how have the clients of JESS3
changed over time?
And how's the focus
of the work?
All right, so maybe those
are a little bit
related in some ways.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: So in terms of
head count, one thing we've
always done is, it's been
mostly contractor.
And we'll do kind of
permalancer, someone who is
permanently part of the team but
you don't bring on as that
full-time employee
with benefits.
And that model has been
incredibly successful for us
because then we're able to kind
of throttle up and down.
It's known by both ends that
it may be that way.
So first and foremost, relying
more on contractors, less on
full-time head count.
The second thing, as far as the
ways that the clients have
changed over the years.
We did Busboys and Poets, their
logo, helped with their
mural in Washington, DC.
A really just amazing restaurant
and entrepreneur
Andy Shallal.
That was one of Jesse's
first clients.
He built the entire website
on Blogger.
And designed it all himself and
hacked it together because
he's not a programmer, per se,
but he's a designer and he
figured it out.
And we would still have that
client while we started
picking up clients like
Nestle and Pfizer.
And we started working, kind
of bridging with having
agencies do overflow.
So we'd get hired by
agencies to work on
subcontractor basis.
And I will say, it was a painful
process to go from the
small business servicing because
we had a price point
that we could make a little
bit of money.
And at the time, it was
just subsidizing.
Jesse and I both had
full-time jobs.
And at that point, it was just
kind of mad money to go on
vacation or something.
But what happened when we both
quit our jobs and all of a
sudden we had a few employees,
it got real.
And the pricing needed to get
real to reflect that.
And our previous clients that
we were still servicing at a
certain price point,
it wasn't working.
So we had to--
I guess the term might be fire
clients or have that tough
conversation.
And that was probably one of the
hardest things I've ever
had to do in this position of
six years is no longer work
with certain clients
because they had an
expectation of a price.
But in order for me to cover
overhead full-time and also
our talent pool, we just kept
trying to increase and
increase the kind of people
we were bringing in.
So the price of their time went
up, so then we had to
pass it on to the customer.
So that was a difficult
transition.
And I would say that all
occurred probably about 2010.
And by 2011 and 2012, we'd been
100% direct to brand, no
agency overflow work.
And been able to keep our
pricing consistent, so that
there aren't those conversations
again.
MEGAN SMITH: We have a couple
more over here.
Let's see.
So someone interested in getting
to-- it doesn't say
from where.
For someone who's just starting
out in tech, how do I
get into information design?
Where would you start?
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Well, I would
definitely start with being
comfortable with wire framing.
And I wire frame on
a whiteboard.
I often take photos of things
that I've sketched out.
But just being comfortable with
drawing and using Adobe
Illustrator is also what our
information architects use.
It doesn't have to be high
fidelity in the way that if
you see some really elaborate
UX work that a web
designer might do.
But having the wire framing
and the drawing skill is
incredibly important.
The second thing to be thinking
about is to start
looking at what kind of data
sets are available.
And start thinking about how
you might pair them.
One thing we did with Google
during the primaries is we
would take a Gallup data set.
Then we would take a CNN poll.
We would take the exit,
actual outcome.
And then we'd take Google
Search data.
And just being able to look at
multiple types of data and be
able to kind of storytell.
So start thinking about data
and information, but then
also, find a way to draw
and think through
kind of some sketching.
And Edward Tufte, I would say
he does a great course three
times a year throughout
the country.
Try to take one of
his courses.
They're pretty theoretical, but
I think it starts getting
your mind thinking about it.
And it's not as intimidating
as it sounds.
You really can have that lo-fi
wire framing process.
And then you can hand it off to
someone else on the design
line, and they can kind of bring
it to life and do some
of the more beautiful, kind of
sexy visualization things.
BETSY MASIELLO: Do you find that
people in your team make
that transition from starting
out with wire framing?
How hard a transition is that
to make from, I don't really
know what I'm doing?
I'm going to learn how to do
this first easy thing, and
then sort of get into
the harder, more
technical roles over time.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: I would say we
have a lot of people coming
in who have a strong
background in
research and analysis.
We've had people that
are history majors,
who are former reporters.
So they understand
how to storytell.
And all they need to do is
partner with the next person
sitting kind of along
the continuum.
In this case, it's Tiffany.
And be able to work with
her to interpret that.
And she's as much a designer
as she is a strategist.
So it's kind of a fusion
of the two.
I would say her role
is that linchpin.
And then, the next one down
the line is that kind of
creative artist, who may not
have any concept or any
mathematical or statistical
background, but they're really
good at making things
look beautiful.
And having the wire frame gives
them some parameters and
helps them understand the
relationship between data.
I think one thing that we did
early on was institute the
wire frame in our infographic
and even
our storyboard process.
Whereas, we see a lot of
people-- and if you've seen a
bad infographic, this is
probably what they did.
They had an idea and some
information, and then they
designed it.
Just went straight
to graphic color.
And they skipped over
that process.
And I think that's an incredibly
important process
because that's when you work out
the kinks of, well, does
this make sense?
Am I really telling a story or
am I just making it look good?
Why are we doing this?
What's the goal?
What are you trying
to [INAUDIBLE]?
There's two questions here that
are related to something
you guys were talking
about before.
One is sort of talking about how
companies can involve more
women and starting early ages.
But also talking about biggest
challenges in social in 2013.
I actually think that part of
one of the answer says that
you were talking about, you guys
are both doing big data.
You're doing visualization.
There are a lot of jobs
that people predict.
We need data scientists.
We need visualization.
We need people.
In some ways, these kinds of
jobs, as an enticement to
young people, young
[INAUDIBLE].
And also, sort of as a social
challenge, just being able to
see in big data.
I don't know if you guys would
talk a little bit about it.
I forget the number of jobs that
it's predicted are going
to be in this area, but it's
thousands and thousands.
BETSY MASIELLO: It's
in the millions.
MEGAN SMITH: That we need
to get ready for.
And like the beginning of
computer science, probably
most of the people coming
to these jobs won't--
in terms of computer science,
people didn't have computer
science degrees because the
departments weren't there yet.
And so people came from math
and economics and art,
whatever engineering.
And so in the same way for
data visualization, other
places, they've going to
come from all over.
So it's huge opportunity for
people for career growth if
they're interested.
So I don't know if you guys
want to talk a little bit.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Well, I would
have loved some encouragement
from the teachers who saw
that I loved math.
And then I was really good at
Latin, which is a big kind of
formulaic system.
And there's a great program
going on in England called
Code is the New.
Latin.
And before I remember my parents
always saying, you
need to learn Latin.
You need to learn Latin.
And that was what you were
supposed to do to understand
root language and be successful
in business and
Medical and legal and fields.
But you think about now shifting
that perception of
before it was all about going
into, let's say, law, if you
were going back to our original
five potential
vocations as a child, and making
engineer a really--
engineer, statistician, data
scientist, making that a part
of that choice set.
And educating students not just
at the college level, but
really as they're coming up
and showing them what that
looks like.
And I think that could be a
big disconnect potentially
between classrooms that are
still teaching to some pretty
basic vocational roles to
teaching to the future.
And encouraging any
[INAUDIBLE]
proclivity in math or a
fascination with science or
numbers that they can
parlay that into a
very important field.
That, as you said,
the jobs abound.
MEGAN SMITH: It's interesting
because it's sort of like the
makers, the makers
movement, meeting
sort of design thinking.
So vocation ability to make
things, but also think about
how to transform or invent
or build sort of fits.
It's interesting, there's an
article in "Technology Review"
this month, just a one page
update from Nicholas
Negroponte on the $100 laptop,
the one laptop per child.
And there's some Android
tablets--
getting a phone call.
Sorry.
So of the Android tablets that
are in Ethiopia right now with
some kids who have no access
to literacy and
those kinds of things.
But one of the things he said,
I think there's 400,000 kids
in Uruguay with PCs.
Part of their curriculum,
they're all programming.
So this idea that
all children--
Sue Black in the UK, who's in
computer science field is
thinking that, why shouldn't--
once you've learned to read in,
say second or third grade,
we're teaching kids cooking and
instruction in that way.
Why shouldn't we learn
programming?
It's an instruction.
It's a form.
And so you're starting to see
that actually with the
[INAUDIBLE]
PC.
So getting more coding and
making into the schools I
think will be critical.
LESLIE BRADSHAW: Right.
We learn the quick, brown
fox jumps over--
the typing, and you think about
all the different things
that are systematic and
coding among them.
And the earlier that you
can introduce that,
we do it with language.
It's just another type
of language.
And it is, in many ways, the
new Latin because it is the
universal thing upon which so
much is based in the world.
I like that a lot.
MEGAN SMITH: Well, we are I
think at the end of our time.
Leslie Bradshaw, thank
you so much for
joining us here at Google.
And Betsy for joining me.
And everybody out on
the web page, thank
you for joining us.
I think the series is going to
go all week, and then we'll
expand from there.
Thanks.
BETSY MASIELLO: Great.